I trained a text generation AI on my
video essay scripts then had it write an
essay for me thank you to Nord VPN for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
Manchester by the sea is trying so hard
to be cinematic and funny put them in a
freezer are you serious yes but
something about its writing and
cinematography has me thinking back to
at least some of the classic moments
Manchester by the sea opens with the
shot of a shot fired a shot triggers all
manner of emotions a feeling of pride a
sense of belonging that can be
represented visually it can be a hopeful
reflection of the future or an
emotionally resonant cry for help the
opening of the first shot of a film is
not just a meaningfully shot opening
it's also a meaningfully empty opening
if you think about it we're looking for
an animal and because the footage
originally showed us an actual animal we
can expect to find one a whole page long
building on previous plot elements the
title text actually starts with you know
those days are never quite the same
after a shoot I can't go wrong our first
clue as to when the video will open and
close won't be an interesting one
filmmaker Alejandro Inarritu has stated
that his goal with his film is to open a
cinema in the moment not to depict
what's happening while the opening of a
film can help open your eyes and
possibly help explain something energy
to left open the potential of what will
become of the mistakes made in the first
place
with so much cinema happening in so many
different forms it's difficult to
catalog everything that's happening in
each form in one place with so many
different styles available there's
always the chance that something unique
might be good fits for a particular
style something interesting could be at
the heart of the style with more and
more filmmakers considering a film in
the field the desire to produce an
original visual style emerges into the
filmmaking world with the explosion of
screens digital cameras and the
distribution business many filmmakers
now realize that creating an interesting
and unique look is no easy task with so
many different types of content
available online in a variety of forms
it's not uncommon to find something that
appears on the look side alone or maybe
on the brand's brand name only with so
many different types of effects
represented in film it's easy to
understand why different looks are
needed to make an effect the cameras are
there to capture the action and the
effects are on the actor protagonists as
they would react to the world not the
camera as the character besides design
the 360 degree crop field used on
effects involved a bit of a cork the
camera doesn't always catch the movement
of the character but the illusion that
they're looking at the same thing gives
the effect a more cinematic look
Futurama a future rommel was one of my
favorite shows all year for one the
production was awash in personality from
the hilarious sketches to the serious
character development for being an
interesting time capsule it's also one
of the few shows that gives you access
to a ton of character development
material which may seem like a long shot
but it pays off the spin-offs add more
depth to the story pricing and
availability are a little weird and
Futurama but most shows give you little
details you don't need to know to get a
good experience particular packaging
might be a good idea but it's not what
Futurama is the premise of Futurama is
simple if you go to the Internet and
post amazing things
what you get is retcons of amazing
things that you can link to and watch on
your phone if you want to watch
everything you have to try it out right
out so with Futurama Premium Membership
is easy premium membership goes for
anywhere from $10 to $99 a month that
being said if you're already a
subscriber you can sign up for a 30-day
free trial if you want something
different just go to WWF you trauma comm
or text for two to twenty to sign up for
a month for $10 off your first purchase
so that was the essay written entirely
by the AI I want to talk a little bit
about how I trained it the a I used and
share some other funny little samples
that it generated I trained on a smaller
version of an AI called GPT - that was
released earlier this year and was
developed by open AI basically the AI
takes a word and predicts what words
should come after that but it uses
machine learning to get better and
better at predicting what kinds of words
a human would right to assemble larger
sentences and things like that
so you can feed it a data set of a type
of writing or text information and it
will learn to speak in that style and
get better and better the more you train
it I trained it originally on my scripts
from my video essays but I also tried
training it on a bunch of other things
like passages from the Bible Infinite
Jest
the Dalai Ching it's very good at
mimicking a style but it doesn't create
anything that actually means
anything because it doesn't understand
meaning and you can see that in the
video essay it generated from me if you
just had that playing in the background
and weren't really paying attention to
what it was saying it sounds like
something I could have or would have
written but it's just completely devoid
of any like substance and that was true
of everything else I trained it on it
was able to write things that sounded
like passages from the Bible or sounded
like something David Foster Wallace
might have written but really it's like
some sort of abstract dreamscape version
of those things here's one of the early
ones it generated off of my video essay
dataset sometimes people laugh when they
see people laughing we often learn that
in some situations this is just an
indication that something was well done
in this case the audience was actually
amused by the scene this one I thought
was funny and here I think film par
excellence is literally the state of the
art of visual art Philip Roth John
Coltrane Wes Anderson Steven Spielberg
and David Zuckerberg have both made
things that very few filmmakers and more
than a few are actually successful in
their films are nothing short of seminal
work that formed the foundation for the
broader industry much like the fact that
the Church of Jesus Christ of latter-day
saints is the soundtrack to some
oscar-nominated films so you can see it
like get certain things right like it
was listing a list of names that it's
saying are filmmakers but then it
doesn't know that John Coltrane isn't a
filmmaker and that David Zuckerberg
might be a person but isn't a well-known
person you can also prompt it with a
phrase or a word and see what it
generates from that I prompted it with
Wes Anderson and my favorite two were
these director Wes Anderson's obsession
with the look of shots has become a
source of frustration for David
Letterman Wes Anderson and Denny Villa
new are excited to be bringing you alien
covenant in two episodes sometimes it
would break and do sort of funny things
probably because of the way I format
some of my scripts here are the
character growth sheet here are the
character development sheet here are the
character growth sheet instrumental
instrumental jubilation jubilation
jubilation jubilation that had just kept
saying jubilation over and over again
which I thought was creepy the other
likes thought that this whole thing
brought to mind was that sometimes I
think we as humans creatively get stuck
in a similar pattern to the way this
type of AI is working where we go to
create something and we just sort of
string together bits of things what
we're like oh I know because of all the
movies I've watched all the books I've
read the sum total of everything I've
consumed I'm just going to replicate
what usually comes after this input so I
have this word and then this word comes
next and that's very good for assembling
sort of these things that look and sound
like other great works but when you
really like think about it or really
drill down into it it's there's no
substance there and I think people do
that sometimes with like movies where
they take bits and pieces of inspiration
from everywhere and they're able to
assemble something that sort of has the
skeleton of a Wes Anderson film or
something like that it mimics the style
but when you really look at it the
substance isn't there because the
meaning behind that original style isn't
being replicated so I don't know what
the takeaway is there but I think that
humans do this sometimes too which is
interesting finally I want to thank Nord
VPN for sponsoring this video
Nord VPN is an excellent VPN and if you
go to Nord bpn comm slash Thomas flight
you can get 75% off when you sign up for
3 years and if you use code Thomas
flight you'll get an additional month
for free you might be wondering why you
would need a VPN and the simplest
explanation is are you at all concerned
about your online privacy or security if
the answer is yes you should have access
to and use
a VPN a VPN can be critical when you're
somewhere like China where there's a
firewall you can use a VPN to bypass the
firewall and get around government
censorship we can see with the things
that are happening Hong Kong right now
the VPN is very crucial to spreading
information to the rest of the world and
getting that information out there
getting access to information about
what's really going on
familiarizing yourself with how to use a
VPN and having one around that you can
use is a great thing to do go to Noor
VPN comm slash Thomas plate get yourself
signed up and get access to a VPN today
so you can start protecting your privacy
and securing yourself online thanks so
much for watching I know this was a
slightly different video but I hope
everyone enjoyed it I want to especially
thank my patreon supporters you can go
to patreon.com/scishow and a bunch of
other stuff and I really appreciate
their support helps me do what I do I'll
talk to you guys again next time